[Applaudissements]
c'était il ya quatre ans en thaïlande
j'étais face à cette éléphante 3 tonnes
c'était en train de la nourrir j'étais
dans un camp d' éléphant qui s'appelle
un sanctuaire en fait dire plus
précisément c'est à dire un endroit dans
lequel on réhabilite les éléphants qui
ont été maltraités par les hommes hélas
ce jour là je suis en train de donner à
manger à cette éléphante qui raffolent
de bananes sa maman de partage je me
sens bien je la regarde droit dans les
yeux et il se passe quelque chose de
particulier qui peut être vous l'avez
vécue si vous avez eu l'occasion de vous
retrouver face à face avec un éléphant
qui est sympa avec vous quand elle vous
regarde ou quand ils vous regardent ils
téléchargent quelque chose il n'ya pas
d'autres mots c'est pas trouvé d'autre
mot pour décrire ce que j'ai vécu c'est
à dire que l'impression est très
particulier à bête en accès direct avec
quelque chose qui vous dépasse
et là je décide de fermer les yeux là
comme la de lâcher prise
sadio quelques instants et coup
sur mon épaule droite
j'ai une sensation bizarre que je
reconnais très rapidement je lève les
yeux et je vois donc face à moi qui
s'est rapproché et j'ai ça trompe sur
mon épaule à une trompe d'éléphant c'est
plus de 1000 muscles si elle veut le
medec tu
entre 10 et 50 mètres en fonction de
l'envié est là mais là je sens quelque
chose de différent je sens une présence
réelle entre elle et moi je me laisse
faire et j'ai vraiment l'impression
c'est la sensation que que j'ai décrit
que je vous dirais aujourd'hui c'est
d'être adoubé adoubé par une éléphante
c'est tellement agréable que je ferme
les yeux une seconde fois j'ai
l'impression de vivre un moment de grâce
au monde échange profond et là quelque
chose de surprenant ce produit en moi
j'ai un doute
j'avais l'impression que la trompe et et
à droite et là j'ai l'impression que la
trompette à gauche et en fait on mange
rouvre les yeux je sais qu'il y en a une
en face et toujours d'ong et j'en ai une
autre derrière qui fait la même chose
moi qui semble costaud habituellement
mais avec mes 100 kg même pas je suis
pris en sandwich entre deux éléphantes
de trois tonnes et honnêtement à ce
moment là la peur n'est en tout cas chez
moi au point que je ne sais pas ce que
je dois faire je ne sais pas si je dois
bouger et ils m'avaient interprétation
de la situation par les éléphants je
vous rappelle on voit 50 m en petits
morceaux
je le sais aussi je les ai vus à ce
moment là j'ai décidé de faire quelque
chose qui vous qui était ce qu'il
fallait faire mais j'en étais pas sûr
j'ai décidé d'eux d'accepter ma peur de
la vivre plus profondément et de
souffler comme ça on a le champ prise
complètement sur ce qui se passait
ça m'a pris une seconde de seconde je
peux vous dire que j'ai une mémoire
d'éléphant sur le sujet chaque micro
secondes de cette situation je peux la
rive là je la connais par coeur
elle est en g et dans mon corps chaque
celui de mon corps a vécu ce moment et
après quelques secondes j'ai senti que
c'était juste pour moi d'être là qui
effectivement j'étais en train de vivre
un moment de gratitude et moments de
grâce et qu'il fallait qu'elle accepte
autrement dit si j'avais laissé la peur
s'exprimer à travers moi je sais pas si
je serai là pour vous parler apprendra à
vivre avec la peur est une bonne idée si
vous arrivez à la gérer si vous voulez
retrouver l'équilibré dans votre vie ne
laissez pas la peur vous conseiller
alors qu'est ce que je faisais là qu'est
ce que je faisais là moi en thaïlande
avec des éléphants en fait j'ai un
compagne des groupes ou j'accompagne des
gens qui ont envie de vivre des
expériences pour apprendre comment il
fonctionne
pour découvrir qui sont ce que moi
j'appelle le leadership naturel quand
vous arrivez dans une salle qu'est ce
qui se passe ce que les gens lèvent la
tête ce qui baisse la tête et ce qu'ils
ont envie d'aller vers vous où il
s'éloigne est-ce que vous paraissez
sympathique
est ce que vous le savez si je reviens
inscrire sur ce que dit eric tout le
monde ment alors ils nous le disent ou
pas davantage avec ses éléphants ou avec
les chevaux ou avec les baleines et les
dauphins avec lequel nous travaillons
ils mentent jamais c'est toujours direct
vous savez exactement ce qui se passe
vous apprenez énormément sur vous et
donc ce jour là je t'ai pas du tout en
exercice j'étais juste en échange
vous le savez mais dans les traditions
ou dans les anciennes traditions les
éléphants représente en fait la mémoire
de la terre quand les baleines
représente la mémoire des océans donc
dans cet échange pour moi j'avais accès
à la mémoire profonde la sagesse
profondes de cette terre je peux pas
vous dire exactement ce que c'est c'est
la sensation que j'ai eu c'est pas
quelque chose que je peux décrire
intellectuellement mais si je n'avais
pas pris le temps de ville ce moment je
ne serais pas ce que ça être pour moi la
première chose que j'avais envie de vous
raconter en dehors de ça c'est pourquoi
vous devriez vous libérer de la peur
vous moi la majorité d'entre nous nous
sommes des prisonniers de la peur nous
avons pas pris conscience de ça ou
peut-être vous l'avez pris vous avez
découvert vous avez pris conscience à
quel point la peur domine et votre vie
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
depuis le temps que je je travaille avec
les émotions que je travaille avec les
dirigeants je travaille avec des
sportifs de haut niveau c'est la peur
qui nous empêchent d'être qui nous
sommes
on peut mélanger une deuxième chose
c'est la honte alors la peur d'avoir
honte et la honte d'avoir peur et vous
avez les principaux sujets qui fait que
vous n'attendiez pas ce pourquoi vous
êtes fait dans la vie votre potentiel ne
s'explique pas
si vous décidez d'aller au delà de ça
d'être à votre place vous aurez besoin
de comprendre comment vous fonctionnez
avec la peur la peur est une fonction
c'est la vigilance
si j'étais pas vigilant j'aurais fait
peut-être n'importe quoi avec ses
éléphantes et peut-être que j'aurai vécu
une autre histoire
donc la peur est intéressante parce
qu'elle me donne une information
mais si je reste dedans elle me fige
elle m'empêche d'agir et l'homme est
dans un système qui est purement
réactionnelle votre esprit va se mettre
à dispo n'ai tourné autour d'une idée
qui n'a rien à voir avec la réalité et
vous allez croire ce que vous avez envie
de croire et ça sera souvent un
dysfonctionnement je crois
fondée manque on vit dans une illusion
dès qu'on est sous la peur notre société
est beaucoup fondée sur la sécurité qui
est une illusion
partout où vous allez dans le monde
l'insécurité est la norme pas dans le
sens que c'est un souhait dans le sens
que c'est un fait et vous apprenez à
vivre avec
parce qu'un bâtiment où vous êtes sous
le charme de cette illusion vous est
manipulable
chaque fois que vous acceptez ou vous
croyez que vous allez être en sécurité
systématiquement en toutes circonstances
eh bien vous ne le serez pas prendre un
risque dans la vie c'est accepter
d'avoir peur certains d'entre vous ici
ont des examens à passer d'autres vont
sont dans des recrutements entre
d'autres gèrent des sociétés d'autres je
ne sais quoi peut-être ont dit oui un
peu trop vite à une personne et
maintenant la peur est là ou pas moi je
me rappelle très bien j'avais 16 ans
j'avais 16 ans quand j'ai réalisé que
peut-être je ne faisais pas ce que je
voulais faire
j'étais un ancien timide ça soit plus
trop aujourd'hui mais j'avais tendance à
vouloir passer
d'ailleurs les affiches propre à les
décaler tellement jeu je voulais me
cacher j'étais très à l'aise avec mes
amis n'est pas tellement à l'extérieur
et comme beaucoup de timide je parlais
qu'avec mes amis évidemment je lâchais
pas la parole à ce moment là parce que
j'ai besoin de parler pour exprimer tout
ce qui est bloquée et j'ai pris
conscience à quel point la peur min b
j'avais des grands rêves en tant que
sportif ça fait des grands rêves en tant
qu'homme ou jeune homme et je ne tenais
pas la mesure de ce que je pouvais faire
je voulais être champion olympique je
n'ai jamais été
en soi c'est pas bien grave
ou alors en tout cas mon plaisir ça a
été d'accompagner des gens je maintenant
et peut-être que j'étais plus fait pour
accompagner les gens au jeu que des
chanteurs mike et 20 ans quand ma mère
est décédée j'ai compris qu encore
j'avais d'autres peur maintenant j'avais
la peur de la de se voir j'avais la peur
de pas être à la hauteur
puis après quand je me suis marié d'être
un bon mari ou d'habana mans puis quand
j'ai eu des enfants j'en ai bien j'en m4
et bien est-ce que je vais être un bon
père
au fil des ans je n'ai fait que rajouter
des peurs que peut-être je faisais
simplement du tennis j'avais une une
incapacité à prendre conscience de ce
que je vivais et la majorité des gens
qui me connaissent savent que je suis
très entreprenants ils n'auraient pas
des ri de moi que je pouvais avoir peur
j'étais plutôt téméraire que courageux
inconscients du danger
alors je vous raconte ça pas pour parler
de moi simplement pour vous dire que ce
qu'on peut être à l'aise avec un
éléphant qu'on n'a pas de problème
ce que vous allez pas croiser des
éléphants tous les jours et par contre
ce que je sais c'est que vous allez
vivre avec la peur il faut vous
appreniez à bien vivre avec la peur
sinon là vous dominez parce que si vous
laissez la peur vers ce que je sais
c'est qu'elle va dominer votre esprit
est aujourd'hui le monde déjà dominé par
la sécurité
alors je vous raconte une petite
histoire qui ce que j'aime bien raconter
des histoires ça se passe en provence à
une époque il y avait un roi qui
s'appelle roi rené je n'ai pas de là
exactement année dont joue mais à ce
moment là et c'est une époque
particulière la peste existe en france
et au nord de la province on avait
construit un mur pour que la peste ne
rentre pas et un jour le roi rodez qui
était connu pour être un bon chasseur
est en tout cas c'était un art qu'il
pratiquait il avait d'ailleurs acheté ce
territoire pour ça parce que l'origine
c'était des grands territoires de chasse
la provence il était seul en train de
chasser et ce jour là il voit arriver
deux personnages face à lui et il sait
très bien ce que sont ces deux
personnages face à lui il a la mort et
la peste
il va droit dessus
il essaie de les chasser mais il
comprend qu'il pourra rien faire
maintenant ils négocient au bout de
quelques instants il a un deal il à un
accord
j'ai bien dit 200 âmes pas plus pas une
de plus la mort répond pas une deux mois
ok ils sont mis d'accord sur un petit
village qui en face de son château ce
petit village évidemment c'est le petit
village d'irréductibles dont il n'arrive
pas à se séparer
il est content de s'en séparer il
continue sa chasse pendant deux trois
jours
trois jours après il revient et quand
ils commencent à regarder au loin
il vaut de l'année mais peut-être vous
le savez mais quand on meurt de la peste
tombeau de les corps et donc il n'est
pas surprise vandale mais plus approche
de son territoire et plus aperçoit de la
fumée vient aussi de l'autre côté de la
colline c'est à dire du côté de chez lui
alors là il part au triple galop et il
va droit
sur son château il voit effectivement
des bûchers il voit des gens pleurer il
voit des gens crier vos des gens se
plaindre qui demande de l'aide
et là il est hors de lui il avait passé
un accord
ils l'ont pas respectée comme un fou
furieux ils recherchent la mort il
recherche la peste il les retrouve
toutes les deux ensemble ils les stops
on avait un deal non on avait 10 200
âmes
pas une de plus amor répondent oui et
pas une de moins
et alors j'en avais plein partout la
moins regardée dit c'est pas nous
regarde la peste non c'est pas moi leur
aura comprend pas la peur caisse à la
mort qui a sa petite idée évidemment lui
répond alors si c'est pas nous c'est la
peur la peur fait toujours le reste à
part se propage autrement dit si vous
laissez faire la peur ce que la presse
n'a pas emporté la peur le fera
je vous raconte cette histoire en
essayant vous donnez une technique vous
allez apprendre à relâcher le prisonnier
de la peur qui est en vous autrement dit
d'accepter d'avoir peur d'accepter de
ressentir dans votre corps ce qu'est la
peur ne pas l'éviter
sinon vous n'avez aucune chance de
délivrer du courage votre courage n'est
dans vos tripes et il faut être présent
à fait peur ils vont ressentir la
difficulté vous avez moi je peux vous
dire qu'à ce moment là j'avais les
jambes qui tremblaient
j'avais ici un noeud au ventre j'avais
une barre dans le dos pas seulement par
le poids des trompes et gelé encore là
si jamais je me remette dedans relâché
le prize-money de la peur ensuite expiré
lentement prenez du temps
la majorité d'entre vous vous n'allez
pas vous retrouver face à deux éléphants
quand vous aurez des décisions à prendre
vous aurez du temps peut-être pas des
semaines mais sûrement des minutes voire
des heures voire des jours expiré prenez
le temps d'expirer ce qui nous permet de
garder l'émotion vous sont vives la
manifestation troisièmement laisser
disparaître la sensation de peur une
fois que vous la laisse et disparaissent
pour lâcher prise plus rien dans votre
cerveau n'existe que quand vous expirez
vous expirez vos pensées
et ensuite ressentez le choix ressentez
ce qui est juste à faire et vous verrez
vous saurez ce qui est juste pour vous
je l' ai tellement pratiqué fait
pratiquer que je vous propose d'essayer
pas ce soir mais dès que vous en aurez
envie aux et le pratiquer sans penser
spécialement mais elephant aux libéré le
positionner de la peur et vous
retrouverez les équilibres intérieurs
c'est ça mon message
[Musique]
récit
[Applaudissements]